No no
iPhone sbagliato Questa è la tua
punizione adatta Ahia ahia è stato lui
non è vero È stato lui alzati no no no
no alzati non sono stato io ma tanto non
mi hai visto la tua punizione sarà
andare in
prigione digli Qual è la capitale della
Francia
crossa
stupido La maestra è tonta ah Che cos'è
quello mio ingrediente
segreto cheo
Billy Sì
[Musica]
[Risate]
sì Devo pulire tutti gli alunni che non
studiano le vostre dà Oh mio
[Musica]
Dio
siamo tornati AA
scuola ma dove sarà la
maestra non lo so io non l'ho vista
vista Neanch'io l'ho vista Oh No
speriamo che non sia la maestra
dell'altra volta te la
[Musica]
ricordi
Buongiorno ragazzi ma è lei sì
no sì proprio lei oggi vi metterò alla
prova Avete studiato inglese Sì sì io
studiato io ho studiato e tu hai
studiato inglese Eh più o meno Più o
meno sì sì ho studiato tu un pochino ho
studiato strud craf FR e tu Io non ho
studiato Se tu non hai studiato inglese
io ti rimetterò in prigione per una
settimana e dormirai qua a scuola ma
Mi fa male la pancia posso tornare a
casa Adesso vedi che ti è passato tutto
il mal di pancia è passato il mal di
pancia ma mal di testa Ehi tu Billy
cambia banco così almeno ti tengo
sott'occhio Uff maestra Ma io stavo bene
nel mio
banco tu schippen Spostati da lì Fammi
mettere a me Spostati Spostati da lì è
veloce maestra
Guarda eh Dammi questo che è il
mio lo si Devon trattare male compagni
hai capito ma io
non Ahia Così impari Ah È tutta colpa
tua stupido scienziato brutto puzzolente
prima Challenge con gli occhi bendati
dovrete pescare tre colori di pennarelli
da questa scatola avete le bende sul
banco mettetele subito Sì sì Eccomi
messa ho messo la
benda sono pronto Non ci vedo niente È
tutto buio Ma cosa devo fare Ma come
schiapp ben non hai ascoltato neanche
tutte le regole forse non ho capito bene
Però tutto buio Continuo a vedere più
niente ma proprio a me doveva dare
questa benda Che brutta Ti devi
accontentare E se piate ancora le tue
ossa Anita Prendi tre colori
Ok vediamo che colori
sono blu viola e nero dai non mi è
andata troppo male tranne il nero però
sono dei colori carini Dai visale pri
colori Sì ok allora dov'è
qui e allora ho scelto tre colori pronti
Verde Rosa e grigio Vabbè il grigio non
mi piace tantissimo però son belli
comunque ma non è rosa quello è rosso ho
detto Rosa era rosso rosso ora te Billy
va bene tocca a me e vediamo un
po' come ha usate
sbirciare sbirciare ma io non l'ho
sbirciato non ho
fatto cos'è questo
[Musica]
di di
formaggio che puzza
cos'è Ma che schifo Vai il calzino Che
schifo calzino di schippen così vai a
sciare non lo faccio più però ho trovato
il giallo il marron
cacca il rosa non va
bene principessa schiappe Ora tocca a te
cosa devo fare devi prendere tre colori
Dove sono i
colori metti
qua
Ah i colori che preferisco c'è sempre il
verde mi piace moltissimo il verde e poi
c'è anche quello Turchese sono proprio i
colori che io amo Bellissimi questi
colori ora disegner il mio ritratto se
mi disegner male le vostre
dita che la Challenge abbia
[Musica]
inizio Ok devo riuscire a disegnare la
maestra al meglio possibile devo farla
il più carina possibile e devo usare
questi tre colori Ok
inizio
proverò a farla molto carina così almeno
non mi taglia le
[Musica]
dita è arrivato il mio momento di
vendicarmi E userò questo
[Musica]
colore con questo colore io posso fare
qualunque
ritratto Se userete solo un colore le
vostre
dita
tempo
scaduto di già io non l'avevo
finito Ecco il ritratto che ti ho fatto
Spero che ti piaccia Un po' ti somiglia
Ma sembra
Elsa chi
Elsa ma no ti somiglia un pochettino
No però devo dire è
bello Quindi Eh non mi taglierai le dita
No Ah meno male mi sono salvata Vitale
Fammi vedere il tuo disegno Questo è il
mio
disegno Oh mio Dio che brutta No no è
maestra bravissima l'ho anche scritto è
bravissima Ma è bruttissima sembra Bibi
casse lunghe Questa è la tua punizione
adatta Allora maestra Io ho fatto un
capolavoro l'ho fatta uguale uguale se
tu mi hai fatto la faccia di cacca vedi
cosa ti faccio Eh no non ho fatto la
faccia del cacca Ci mancherebbe altro e
invece l'ho
fatta No no è il mio foglio maestra no
no no no no no no no ci ho messo tanti
impegni tanti impegni significa questo a
me non mi sembra no
maest
è la tua
punizione preso in testa ah in testa di
nuovo che cosa vuole fare che cosa vuole
fare
no
maestra Ma sempre in prigi
finisco No cosi impari Voglio sperare
che il tuo disegno sarà migliore lo
faccio vedere una attimo Secondo
me Mamma mia che
brutto non è brutto e non è così brutto
è molto meglio di quello di Billy sembri
tu sembro
io non sembro io no non sembro io però
un pochino però un pochino è vero sembro
io Ora visto che non ti sei
impegnato Ti taglierò le dita Ah dai non
le Anzi visto che ti sei impegnato un
po' così io sono la maestra del Taus
Quindi adesso te l'ai dritto dai dai dai
dai dai
dai così Imp a farmi così
brutta ah Ah questi bambini questa
Challenge l'ha vinta Anita Evviva anche
se ha detto che ho disegnato Elsa almeno
il mio disegno non era schifoso come
quello degli altri ha vinto la prima
Challenge speriamo di vincere anche la
seconda Ma voi avete lasciato un mi
piace nello scorso video vi ho detto che
se il video avesse raggiunto i 5000 mi
piace avremmo fatto un altro video con
la maestra cattiva se questo video
Invece raggiunge i 6000 mi piace faremo
un altro video con la maestra trita ossa
quindi cliccate mi mi piace qua sotto
adesso passiamo alla seconda
[Musica]
Challenge Challenge di inglese io
scriverò la parola all lavagna e voi lo
dovete disegnare chi sbaglia avrà una
penitenza Anita vieni all
lavagna disegna
Watermelon Ok Lo so lo so lo so È solo
che non so se lo so disegnare bene ma ci
provo
Watermelon il melone nel water wow no
Mamma mia che
schifa sembra un panino aspetta Lo lo
ridisegno
meglio Watermelon e anguria giusto Sì
brava Meno male Mi sono scampata la
penitenza Vitale vieni all lavagna
disegna Wax eh Wax
Oh non puoi CH aiuto Ahia ahia ahia
Ah adesso io lo so che cos'è Ecco
significa disegnalo
[Musica]
ehx va va
va una vasca da bagno si capisce che è
una vasca da bagno ha sbagliato
significa ceretta e praticamente questa
si assomiglia un po' alla ceretta no
tipo metti la striscia e poi eh no no no
ma che cosa vuoi
fare
[Musica]
Ah così impari Ao studiare Ah R voglio
dietro i miei peli Ah ah ah vado a posto
vado a
posto scappa in vio la lavagna disegna
Eyes Shadow Eyes Shadow
Sì Shadow difficile disegnare Però credo
che ci
[Musica]
riuscirò i Shadow Ma cosa è i Shadow è
una March mano piede che fa e si va da
tutte le parti hai sbagliato skippen hai
fatto un disno schifoso High Shadow
significa ombretto E ora la tua
punizione sarà metterti l'ombretto
l'ombrello ma oggi non sta più
[Musica]
frendo che
bello
Ah che
bello che
soddisfacente alza questa
testa che
bello Sono sicuro che sarò
bellissimo sicuro
Ah ho finito il mio capolavoro ti vuoi
vedere le
schiappe
[Musica]
ma sono
bellissimo
[Musica]
bellissimo ma cosa bellissimo Se sei una
capra Vai a posto mamma mia Billy Vieni
alla lavagna e muoviti Eccomi tocca a me
Io ho studiato l'inglese Eh disegna
Shoes Allora Disegniamo Shoes Allora SH
Io lo sapevo Shoes l'avevo studiato
disegna muovi
zitto e anche la mchina perfetto Shoes
hai disegnato di nuovo la cacca come ti
sei permesso no Maestra maestra dammi
dammi Questo ecco sei tu adesso sei tu
Ma mi assomiglio non c'è gli
occhiali Ok adesso mi assomiglio Questo
è il tuo ritratto Shoes significa scarpe
e siccome non hoin atto Questa è la tua
punizione Ma che cosa sta facendo
maestra la tua punizione è
questa Che
schifo Non mi sento tanto bene
bentis questa era la scarpa più
puzzolente al mondo e ora vai a posto Se
lo ti ti picchio con la
scarpa Vai vado a posto
V vado vado a posto vado vado vado vado
a posto vado a posto Devo punire tutti
gli alunni che non studiano Chen VII la
lavagna Head ben disegna handb Head ben
io forse ho
[Musica]
capito
headband Questo è quello che vuol dire
headband Cos'è questa cosa hai sbagliato
headband vuol dire cerchietto non questa
erba questa erba ora la tua punizione
sarà metterti il cerch etto m una
femminuccia una femminuccia ora vai a
posto dai su Forza vai
vai questa parola di sicuro Billy Bullo
la indovinerà Billy vien lavagna disegna
Poop Poop
Poop però maestra aspetti Eh perché non
sembra Pop qua Ci manca un pezzo forse
non l'ha scritto
bene
fatto Ah ok sì sì è scritto meglio
quindi
Pop può
essere forse lo so vediamo Vediamo se è
[Musica]
questo eh un pupo pupo pupo pupo un
bambino che piange vedi
piange da quanto mi sto sentendo male
mamma mia dai C'è non è significa cacca
cacca
buno disegnata prima ora Questa è la tua
punizione Allora innanzitutto Chiudi G
occhi e Siediti Ok chiudi chiudi gli
occhi Chiudi Eh sì ce li ho
[Musica]
chiusi
Apri Ma che schifo
Apri cacca che
schifo cacca che
schifo
maest
Dimmi una cosa dietro la
Schena cosa Controlla guarda un
biglietto
Sca no no no no la SC No nel senso non
so non l'ho fatto io no no no non l'ho
fatto io No veramente lo giuro non l'ho
fatto io Ah
ah ah ahia ahia F la Meza scuola basta i
basta abbassati abbassati Ah adesso stai
zitto finalmente Comunque ti devo dire
una una brutta notizia sei bocciato
anche
quest'anno Ah dimenticavo l'ultima
cosa
Ah una
cosa Ah finalment Sta zitto tutti e tre
quest'anno siete promossi
ce l'ho sempre io la vostra maestra
tritta
ossa e quest'anno sarò più cattiva che
mai avete fatto i compiti per le vacanze
Perché senò le vostre
ossa Io sì li ho fatti maestra Io li ho
fatti i compiti che cosa stai dicendo Io
non li ho fatti tu li hai fatti E
allora fatti dove non li ho fatti e tu
per lì non li hai fatti peggio per voi
Ho tre botte in
testa Ah sì E allora adesso vi interrogo
e vediamo se avete studiato
interrogazione No ma già il primo giorno
vai tu vai tu vai tu ma io non ho
studiato non ho nemmeno fatto i compiti
per le vacanze Figurati giio Per
te secchiona Sei una secchiona Sì Una
secchiona
Ma sei proprio Bullo mi hai sporcato
tutto mi hai sporcato questa mi inza
proprio bene e adesso faremo
un'interrogazione con un argomento a
vostra scelta ci sarà da
divertirci argomento a scelta io ho una
cosa bellissima di cui parlarvi una
novità incredibile ma ve la dirò dopo
quando sarà il mio turno voi nel
frattempo cliccate mi piace qua sotto
perché se questo video raggiunge i 6000
mi piace ci sarà un altro episodio con
la maestra cattiva argomento a scelta
eh Ho
un'idea posso preparare qualcosa da
mangiare un argomento scelta ma io non
ho studiato niente però beh io posso
fare i miei
scherzetti Guarda Quante cacche il dito
fitto questo uno
scoreggio
ah ci sono tanti SC e c'ho anche il
telecomando della cacca
telecomandata stai facendo Gio
[Musica]
casino fatto malissimo Vale vieni alla
lavagna e dimmi qual è il tuo argomento
a scelta Eccomi maestra Eccomi Allora io
come dimostrazione ho portato e la mia
mio pentolino e io farò una zuppa di
legumi e verdure e ti pare che Vitale
non qualcosa che riguarda il cibo come
sempre Scommetto che dopo la vorrà pure
mangiare praticamente Si parte con
setano carota e cipolla si taglia tutto
sottino sottile sottile sottile sottile
poi si mette Qui si fa il soffrito
soffrito Basta ci stai mettendo troppo
tempo Ahia Ah ma per preparare le cose
ci vuole un po' di tempo no E come fanno
a cuocersi Sen no Ma cosa cavolo c'entra
la zuppa a scuola si fa la zuppa non c'è
neanche anche la cucina Ora vedrai tu
cosa devo cuocerla
meglio che brutta mamma mia questa è la
zuppa però marca e infatti quelle sono
le calze di skippen stanno di formaggio
e
cavolfiore Così impari a non aver
studiato e poi la zuppa non c'entra
nulla a scuola eh Va bene maestro Ho
capito però almeno posso finire di fare
la zuppa Sì ok però ti do solo 10
secondi è arrivato il mio momento di
entrare in azione manca il mio
ingrediente segreto la
cacca 10 9 8
12 3 2 1 0 basta hai
finito finito ce l'ho fatta giusto in
tempo giusto in tempo Adesso è l'ora di
assaggiarla Eh sì sì non vedo l'ora non
vedo l'ora è la mia parte preferita
assaggiare le cose da
mangiare cosa che schifo la cacca dentro
la zuffa Come ti sei permesso cos'è me
la volevi far mangiare come la cacca ma
non sono stato io sono sicura che questo
è uno scherzo di Billy Non è possibile
che Vitale ha fatto una zuppa del genere
Eh no Ma come Ma come ti viene in mente
ma non è che io perché sono il buulo
devo sempre fare gli scherzetti io non
c'entro niente Io questa zuppa non
l'assaggio l'assaggi tu no no io questa
zuppa non l'assaggio non l'assaggio No
no no non sono stato io a metterla la
cacca che stai facendo
Che puzza che
schifo e Adesso tocca ad Anita Anita
vieni alla lavagna ho una novità
importantissima da darvi la novità
importantissima è che è appena uscito in
preordine il mio nuovissimo libro La
città stregata gli investigatori del
mistero leggendo questo libro vi
trasformerete in dei veri investigatori
del mistero come noi infatti c'è proprio
un mistero da risolvere e Voi riuscirete
a risolvere il mistero prima di arrivare
alla fine del libro Mi raccomando
preordino subito perché con il preordine
Riceverete anche una sorpresa che bello
il nuovo libro diita Stories dammelo
aspetta aspetta aspetta Facciamo una
cosa te lo presto così puoi leggerlo Ok
va bene e però Trattalo bene perché è un
libro speciale e potrebbe avere anche
dei poteri nascosti Wow Non vedo l'ora
di scoprire l'alfabeto segreto pre
ordinatelo anche voi Così scopriremo il
mistero tutti insieme È bellissimo il
nuovo libro di Anita e poi in copertina
ci sono anch'io modestamente infatti
Nella storia ci sono anch'io e farò
anche tante cose simpatiche oltre a
mangiare ovviamente preordino subito per
scoprire tutte le cose che combinano
nella storia il nuovo libro di Anita
Stories regali segreti una storia
vincente alfabeto segreto
no deve essere mio devo rubarlo devo
rubarlo subito come posso fare Billy
vieni all lavagna Sì tocca a me non ho
sentato niente ma questa può essere
l'occasione per rubare il
libro ecc maestra Allora Billy hai
studiato vero Almeno questa volta che tu
non studi mai eh se ho studiato io certo
che ho studiato ho studiato matematica
ing il libro di il inglese
Ah cosa stai facendo niente Volevo
volevo vedere la copertina è così bello
Posso guardare la copertina
Ah Non ti azzardare a toccare il libro
di Anita Ah va bene va bene mi hai fatto
malissimo eh maestra io non ho studiato
in questa vacanza sono andato in giro a
fare i miei scherzetti però posso
parlare di una cosa che so benissimo e
cioè dei miei scherzetti per esempio
Guarda
questo
Guarda guarda una Vitale
unaa Ma che schifo e una lei che schifo
Billy e poi maestra guardi Ah sembra un
megafono piccolino ma in
[Musica]
realtà
cosa lì come ti sei
permesso Sì Mi scusi maestra e stavo
facendo vedere i miei scherzi ma c'ho
anche un dito un dito finto maestra eh
tiri il
dito Oh lo può prendere per favore
maestra lo può
prendere Sì
[Musica]
sì è
bellissimo eh maestra Eh sì questa cosa
Sì sì ancora
[Applauso]
ancora Questa sì che è una puzza
incredibile Queste sono le tue scorregge
quando tu sei
[Applauso]
addormentato come hai usato a fare
questi scherzi eh maestra no iio iio
sempre a finire così ah ah E ora
abbassati perché mi devo abbassare
abbassati Che cos'è
questo e ora è quello che ti meriti sei
il re della cacca dovrai tenere sempre
questo capello Vai a posto
Uffa Che cos'è no il cappello di cacca
va bene Io vado a
posto
m Billy Che cos'è dietro la schiena
eh no no no niente è solo la
mia
puzza tasto puzzolente c'ho solo il mio
tasto puzzolente lo metto qui va bene
non ho nient'altro
nient'altro passiamo alla prossima
[Musica]
Challenge seconda Challenge sarà la
Challenge invece dell'inglese sarà dello
spagnolo Vediamo se avete studiato lo
spagnolo Vitale Vieni alla lavagna Hola
professora Certo che sono lo spagnolo
giuros
paia
burrito nachos anche nachos voni nachos
Tra l'altro Vitale Disegna il
significato di questa
parola Caracol
Caracol non sono sicurissimo però penso
di aver azzeccato il significato di
questa parola che in realtà viene da due
residenze cara e col e praticamente è la
colla dello Slime no Ma cosa sta dicendo
Vit È facilissimo ma ha sbagliato Chissà
quale sarà la sua
punizione praticamente la colla dello
Slime però è cara quindi è cara col è un
po' costosa è cara col Ho indovinato No
Come no significa lumaca lumaca Ma io
non lo sapevo Questa è la tua punizione
per non aver studiato spagnolo Oh
no che schifo ce l'ho qui sulla fronte
Ma lo devo tenere tutto il tempo qui Sì
sì proprio così oh no che schifo la
lumaca è
fronte Vai a posto Ok va bene vado a
posto con la
lumaca sono riuscito a rubare il libro e
lo leggerò prima di
tutti Sbrigatevi a preordinarlo perché
sennò io mi leggerò la fine e ve la
rivelerò
rovinandolo
Quindi fate in fretta e preordino Anita
vieni alla lavagna Eccomi maestra eh
disegna Pelota
Pelota io sono più brava in inglese non
in spagnolo forse è Pelota Forse ho
capito Pelota vuol
dire pelata cioè è una persona che non
ha i capelli Pelota giusto No Pelota
vuol dire palla Oh no ho sbagliato io
che studio sempre ho sbagliato e ora che
cosa mi farà questa è la tua punizione
ah
ahia Billy Vieni alla lavagna Eh sì
ecra disegna maton maton ma è troppo
facile maton maton eh il mattone aspetta
come faccio a disegnare il mattone stai
scherzando È un mattone Sì l'ho
disegnato malissimo ma è un mattone No
non significa mattone certo
matton significa Bullo Sì come
te un maton Io sono maton Sì sì sono
unon
basta ah ah ahia ahia
ahia il cappello hai rotto ah ah
ahia
Ah il mio libro lo aveva rubato
bly maestra Billy aveva rubato il libro
no stai scherzando G avevamo detto
quanto è prezioso il libro e lui l'ha
rubato no stai scherzando Non è vero non
l'ho rubato io dov'è No non l'ho rubato
io non l'ho rubato
io Ah non lo so perché era lì non non
penso io è stato vitale che mi ha fatto
uno scherzo a
meato e ora tu andrai in quella prigione
no i in prigione
no Sì il prore il
prore maestra ha rotto tut Rigione Non
mi sento bene cosi Fi a rubare il libro
siamo tornati a scuola nuovissima
Challenge a scuola Chi vincerà le tre
Challenge sarà promosso chi invece
perderà anche solo una delle Challenge
verrà bocciato per ogni Challenge ci
saranno le stelline d'oro Chi vincerà la
Challenge collezion le varie stelline
d'oro e alla fine chi avrà più stelline
d'oro verrà promosso e vincerà la
Challenge e dovremo affrontare la
maestra cattiva ma ora siete pronti i
partecipanti di questa Challenge sono
io professor
schippen
Vitale Billy Bullo che hai da
guardare Ehi Ma chi sarà la
maestra io non ho visto nessuno ancora
Eh forse deve ancora arrivare magari
arriverà momenti Eh sento dei passi sta
arrivando sta arrivando
[Musica]
eh Oh forse ha sbagliato
classe ma sei tu la
maestra Io sono la maestra trit Rossa TR
la maestra trita ossa Ma se sei una
bambina scusa cosa hai
detto ho detto che sei una bambina non
puoi essere una maestra
[Musica]
ma hai capito Adesso ho capito perché
maestra trita
ossa Mi sa che è meglio comportarci bene
con questa maestra nella mia classe
dovete stare e composti se no le vostre
ossa
e Ok ok maestra saremo sicuramente
seduti bene composti Ma qual è la prima
lezione come prima lezione sarà la
Challenge di inglese chi sbaglia avrai
una penitenza di che penitenza si tratta
lo scoprirete fra poco siete pronti
Avete studiato inglese Yes yes yes Io
adoro l'inglese La mia materia preferita
non vedo l'ora di iniziare la verifica
cioè la Challenge inglese Sì dai più o
meno me la cavo Bonjour moner Sì
sì inglese Io conosco solo tedesco Ah sì
ma chi se ne frega Tanto io copierò di
sicuro Allora vediamo chi ha studiato
iniziamo la
[Musica]
Challenge a og
Turn are la parola che c'è scritta qua
chi sbaglia avrà una penitenza se vi
vedo copiare o imbrogliare perrette
chiusi qua in prigione Ehi se ti fate
per me lasciate un mi piace qua sotto
Vitale vieni qua alla lavagna Oh no io
per
primo dunque quindi se ho capito bene
devo disegnare qui il significato di
questa parola qui in inglese Sì io io io
io lo so che cos'è Ham io lo so Lo so lo
so Hammer
Hammer Hammer si dice Hammer
Sì sì adesso mi ricordo adesso mi
ricordo Hammer America ha sbagliat
Hammer significa martello Questa è la
tua punizione adatta Ahia ahia ahia la
penitenza di Vitale era proprio il
martello seconda parola Anita Vieni alla
lavagna Eccomi eccomi eccomi Allora io
lo so lo so lo so lo so la parola è
teacher e Ah vero Devo
disegnarla non offenderti se la disegno
male mamma mia l'ho disegnata proprio
brutta Comunque teacher vuol dire
insegnante giusto Sì brava Finalmente
qualcuno che ha studiato Sì sì sì ma
posso parlare un po' in inglese adesso
perché io adoro parlare in inglese adoro
in inglese e posso parlare un pochino in
inglese no vai a
[Musica]
posto Ora è il turno di schiapp eccomi
qua ora la parola che ho scelto per te è
WS tieni WS non capisco bene che cosa
sia però il disegno lo
[Musica]
faccio ma cosa è è un disegno il mio
disegno maestra ma non significa questo
e non so cosa dire Però per me questo
orso è questo ora la tua penitenza sarà
mettere la mano nei
Fermi Metti subito metto la mano sui
fermi
No no no la mano sui fermi No la mano
sui vermi
no
Worms vuol dire vermi e quindi la
penitenza era a mettere la mano nei
vermi questa maestra è un po' cattiva
adesso vai a
[Applauso]
posta tocca a te Billy Vieni alla
lavagna Eccomi eccomi
maestra disegna jale
tieni jale sì ah
Jail Sì io lo so cosa vuol dire Jail io
lo so e disegnalo Sì adesso lo disegno
eh un secondo un secondo che mi fa male
la pancia un secondo posso Posso girarmi
Mi fa male la pancia Sì sì
sì
brigola scusa eh come stai imbrogliando
No no non sto Inia Guarda
guardi
finito finito ho finito Non è vero stavi
guardando sul telefono non ce l'ho il
telefono non ce l'ho no e cos è questo
questo telefono ora sarà se
sequestrato per favore ma ora la tua
punizione Sà andare in prigione No in
prigione no sì subito S in brogliato E
giusto devo andare in prigione brava
maestra maestra Ma perché mi cho in
prigione Perché è imbrogliato Ah E vabbè
Almeno così non faccio lezione come hai
detto no maest no no dai dai dai dai Son
già son già qui son
già sedere vuoi parlare ancora no no B
St qua St qua perché questa ci doveva
capitare
[Musica]
secondo round Vitale Vieni alla lavagna
Io lo so io lo so che cos'è E tu
cacche che schifo ma no non è cacche è
cake e poi parli tu che ti chiami
schippen mm è un bel nome schippen
eh qui mi sento molto molto sicuro di
indovinarla questa quando si tratta di
cibo D'altronde allora quindi cake
[Musica]
abbiamo torta con la candelina Ho messo
anche la candelina perché sono
bravissimo Bravo bravo Vitale però
quando si tratta di cibo tu lo sai
sempre quindi adesso dov'è la mia torta
Ma che dovevi solo disegnare Eh ma io
m'aspettavo la ricompensa No prima chi
sbaglia tipo prima che ho sbagliato Ho
preso il martello in testa adesso che ho
indovinato Mi aspeta la torta no se non
vai a posto subito te ne do
altre aiuto vado a posto vado a posto
vado a posto vado a posto Ahia ma anche
quando lo indovino prendo le martellate
Anita vieni alla lavagna Eccomi eccomi
eccomi la parola bepack lo so benissimo
che cos'è Ora lo disegno
subito ho paura che sembri una tazza ma
non è una tazza lo
giuro cosa che non so disegnare molto
bene Comunque ho disegnato uno zaino si
capisce Sì brava brava ha indovinato
Evviva Ho vinto anche questo round Sì
però ok ora vai a posto tocca okok a un
altro Disegna la parola Socks la parola
stock disegno
bene Ma cos'è questa schifezza Non
significa questo questo il mio disegno
per me è un significato Ma poi cosa è
questa schifezza Soc significa calze
Innanzitutto
si
Questa è la tua
penitenza un calzino
puzzolente odore zitto Ah che
[Musica]
schifo Ok ora vai a posto Sì ma vado
subito a
posto anzi questo te lo tieni pure tu Ah
che
schifo
prima Challenge completata la vincitrice
è Anita Oh che bello Evviva ho vinto la
prima Challenge ho preso la mia prima
stellina speriamo di vincere anche le
altre Uffa Spero di vincere la prossima
lei è già in vantaggio Ma perché non ho
vinto io sono così bravo in
inglese Sì sì già l'ho visto quanto
sembrava un inglese prima hai detto pure
Cac invece che cake tornate tutti a
posto Adesso inizia la seconda
Challenge Adesso faremo la Slime
Challenge prenderete tutti quanti gli
ingredienti vincerà chi farà lo Slime
più bello deciderò io chi sarà il
vincitore della seconda
Stellina io prendo
questo schiappe scegline uno va bene
prendo questo perché questo mi piace
molto poi c'ha un colore che ho ho
sempre amato no Lo volevo io quello rosa
tu quale vuoi
adesso Vabbè prendo il giallo Allora Ehi
ma il giallo lo volevo io perché non hai
preso il verde prendine uno l'ho preso
tieni il buro no ma io non posso neanche
scegliere mi prendo lo scarto degli
altri schiappe Scegli un colore prendo
questo questo è un colore che mi è
sempre piaciuto nelle mie reazioni
quando ero nella laboratorio lì in
Germania Anita Ah io so benissimo che
colore prendere prendo il rosa Wow c'è
un rosa pesca o rosa fragola quale
scelgo proviamo Rosa pesca Non vedo
l'ora di vedere come uscirà lo Slime con
questo Vitale prendine uno e allora
c'abbiamo arancia lime eh kiwi avocado
limone prendo ciliegia prendo ciliegia
che è rosso rosso ciliegia prendine uno
eh Sì maestra io lo so già cosa prendere
io prendo il verde moccio così posso
fare anche gli scherzi ai miei compagni
skippen prendi prendo questo qui Questo
mi ricorda quando ero bambino che facevo
i primi esperimenti con le palline Anita
prendine uno che belli prendo questi
piccolini che belli Vitale prendili Ma
io volevo quelli piccoli li possiamo
scambiare Anita ma sono più belli quelli
silenzio Oh Ufa e a te nulla No come a
me nulla ma no ma io volevo fare le
praline di moccio non le posso fare
adesso ma te ne passerò un paio io dai
grazie Vitale Allora faremo gli scherzi
agli altri a te non te li faccio Oh Ok
Tieni schiappe sceglilo scego questo che
dorato perché il dorato arriva dalla
Polvere delle stelle Io ho sempre
raccolto la polvere delle stelle m Sì
vabbè lasciamo perdere Eh allora io
scelgo questo Celeste bellissimo Vitale
prendi un colo della tua scelta Eh ok Io
prendo quello blu allora eh Fammi
indovinare e io mi devo accontentare di
quello che rimane come sempre vero a te
questo
Marrone ah tanto ve la farò vedere io e
adesso vi darò la colla Chi di voi sa
come si fa uno Slime io io io lo so
faccio tantissimi Slime ho scritto anche
questo libro crea i tuoi Slime in cui ci
ci sono tantissime ricette voi ce
l'avete e qua ci sono tantissime ricette
per creare gli Slime bene voi due tenete
questa colla e voi due tenete questa Ok
grazie E ora che la seconda Challenge
abbia inizio benissimo mi basta cercare
la mia ricetta del crunchy Slime no come
crunchy Slime Maestra maestra Ma lei
c'ha il libro ma che vuoi Noa sì Dammi
questo libro Oh ma mi ci sono tutte le
mie ricette
tu zitto no no no io ti sto aiutando
maestra non me ne frega se mi stai
aiutando adesso stai ridendo però scusi
io prima ho copiato dal telefono e mi ha
messo in prigione adesso lei stava
copiando dal libro e non la metto in
prigione No no no non stavo copiando
stavo solo rileggendo le mie ricette
sono le mie non le sto copiando da
nessun altro ah ma no ma non vale così
basta con questa storia senò vi metto
tutti quanti in prigione ok Ok iniziamo
subito Prendo Slime presto presto presto
F fretta se non ci mette tutti in
prigioni Dami un po' di colla da metti
quiok dobbiamo vincere Noi sì ma non
pensare che per questo siamo divent
amici
aspetta Quest basta così ok anche se non
ho il libro mi ricordo come fare gli
Slime Meno male allora mettiamo un po'
di colla trasparente Ehi ma tu schiaff
sai come si fanno gli Slime devo ancora
imparare nelle mie ricette chimiche
saprò come fare ok Allora inizia
mettendo un po' di colla e ora mettiamo
un po' di colorante Vediamo com'è questo
color
pesca Uh ma sembra rosso proviamo a
mischiarlo vediamo di che colore diventa
Oh
Wow Sembra un bellissimo Rosa adesso
mettiamo i glitter celesti
Wow che belli mischiamo è già
bellissimo e ora per ultimo mettiamo le
palline che nonà Eh sì non ne voglio
mettere troppe senò diventa troppo
crunchy Ecco fatto e ora
mischiamo
Wow
bellissimo Ok Mi basta solo mettere
l'attivatore adesso mettiam poco per
volta
E
mescoliamo
1 2 3 e quattro gocce adesso giriamo
bene mescoliamo Ecco il verde che io
preferisco cosa stai facendo verde
moccio non è verde moccio è verde
foresta Ha ragione la maestra è messo
troppo colorante sembra verde moccio non
è verde moccio è verde No infatti cosa è
Allora è verde foresta mettiamo un po'
di questo che mi ricorda l'oro bosta ne
ho messo anche qua troppo anche nel dito
così
tiriamo bellissimo verde dogato verde
dorato mi ricordo i gioielli di mia
nonna non molte così va bene così così
così così così così e e basta così ma
come il verde il verde moccio lo volevo
fare io per fare gli scherzi a questi
stupidi
compagni invece me l'ha rubata schiappe
l'idea Vabbè Devo trovare una soluzione
devo cambiare colore ma come faccio Ah
ma io lo so come
[Musica]
fare Maestra maestra mi è caduto il
colore Eh vai a prenderlo Sì vado a
prenderlo Fammi passare tu Stai calmo Sì
non ho fatto niente cosa sto facendo non
sto facendo niente Ah ecco il mio colore
verde Sì sì rimane verde il mio colore e
invece il colore cacca e poi devo
prendere un'altra
cosa
Eh io ho ripreso il mio colore maestra
posso tornare a posto
ok il colorante ciliegia che è il mio
frutto preferito tra l'altro Guardate
che colore bellissimo Ho fatto bene a
scegliere ciliegia Questa è più amarena
però voglio fare un Galaxy
Slime adesso aggiungo le palline medie
Io però ne aggiungo poche di queste
perché nel mio Slime le voglio solo come
decorazione non ne voglio mettere
tante ma non sta uscendo ancora a color
cacca mi serve più scuro come faccio a
farlo più scuro Ehi vuoi delle palline
Eh aspetta non guardare il mio Slime
ancora il mio Slime è un segreto uno
Slime segreto Sì dammi qualche pallina e
girati Ok va bene tirle tutte Ma come
posso fare a farlo diventare più scuro
di così io lo volevo proprio
color cacca maestra dimmi eh Posso
questo colore non funziona bene Scusa ma
tu non avevi scelto il verde se tu hai
imbrogliato ritornerai in questa
prigione Ok ma non ho imbrogliato perché
nessuno c'ha le prove come faccio a
farlo diventare color eh C Cioè più
scuro come faccio a farlo più scuro
basta Aggiungere ancora colorante perché
secondo me tu non hai il cervellino Ah
ho capito Va bene provo a aggiungere
altro
colore Uh
maestra no maestra è stato lui non è
vero Sì è stato lui alzati no no no no
alzati non sono stato io ma tanto non mi
hai visto Ah Ma che schifo questa è una
Ca di schia perch puzza no me ne frega
Allora ti devi alzare non ce l'ho ancora
nelle
mani
Oh Aveva ragione la maestra aggiungendo
il colorante è diventato esattamente il
colore che volevo io Ora sì che posso
fare gli scherzi Ah che bello il mio
Time No non puoi vincere tu di nuovo hai
già vinto la stella sì e quindi no Ora
tocca a noi Anzi tocca a me ho io il
modo per rovinargli
Slime con i miei vermicelli Però prima
devo
distrarla
Anita guarda skippen perché che c'è
skippen niente niente Sì No scusa
Pensavo che ti stessi chiamando sai non
mi distrarre No no non ti voglio
distrarre
Eh hai visto la tua stella perché hai
lanciato la mia stella lì perché sì
Perché tu sei troppo bravo a fare gli
Slime Adesso vai così perdi
tempo
[Musica]
silenzio Billy ha lanciato la mia stella
Oh ma sembra proprio cacca Ah che
schifo un po' sciolta un po' più dura
Che schifo perché non si staccando le
mani questa
[Musica]
cacca Guarda Anita Guarda Nita Eh ma che
ma è brutto di F No sto è bruttissimo
senti la
scoreggia cosa stai facendo No maestra
mi dispiace stop tempo scaduto Allora il
voto è due due Sì va bene allora se tu
decidi due per me è 10 a me non mi
risulta Vabbè tocca a me allora il mio
Slime È bellissimo
perché
F Ah che schifo che schifo che schifo Ah
che schifo che schifo che
schifo Non li ho messi io ventra come
non li hai messi tu e chi li ha messi no
lo giuro non li ho messi io non ho messo
io i vermi che schifo chi ha messo dei
tue i vermi Io non sono stato Chi è
stato Allora qualcuno è
stato
fermo lo vedi questo Slime Sì l'ho visto
fino adesso
no ma perché perché sei stato tu a
mettere i vermi ce li avevi lì nel nel
Anco allora lui deve essere bocciato Ma
perché nel mio maestra ma il mio era
bellissimo era uno Slime di
cacca cacca cacca per tut cca cacca
cacca cacca cacca talmente sono
arrabbiata adesso ti rimetto in prigione
Alzati la maestra
No no ma volevo vincere io No volevo
solo vincere io no maestra Dai lasciami
no lasciami è talmente grave quello che
hai fatto quindi sei bocciato Oh figo io
adesso ho più chance di vincere allora
Ecco il mio
Slime cosa sta faccendo la maestra con
il mio Slime tieni Anita Ti ho levato
tutti i vermi è molto bello perché ha un
bel colore ed è elastico Cioè è molto
elastico quindi quindi il voto è
benissimo quindi se il mio voto è
benissimo e schiappa in una presa
insufficiente il bullo è in prigione
Basta che Vitale prenda un sufficiente O
insufficiente e avrò vinto io la
Challenge vediamo che voto prevederà
Vitale Ecco il mio
Slime presentazione e voilà che cosa ne
pensa maestra Allora il tuo Slime è
molto bello bello Cioè è molto
elastico quindi è benissimo lo stesso Oh
anch'io ho preso lo stesso voto di Alisa
Ehi aspetta un momento ma se il tuo voto
è benissimo e il mio è benissimo chi è
che ha vinto questa Challenge Allora la
Challenge l'avete vinta tutti e due
quindi una stell te e una stella a
lui tutti e due sì il mio Slime è
riuscito a prendere lo stesso voto del
tuo beh volevo vincere solo io ma va
bene anche così che AV vinto anche
Vitale dai anch'io potevo vincere e non
ci sono riuscito Però va bene così una
stella a te grazie e una stella a te
grazie La mia prima stella ma io ho due
stelle quindi questo vuol dire che sì
Anita hai vinto tu la Challenge e Ho
vinto io ho vinto io ho vinto i eh di
poco eh di poco di poco mi mancava solo
una stella per per no due stelle per
vincere E non è finita qua perché c'è
ancora una sorpresina per il
bulletto no maestra no maestra no no no
no no no no no maestra No no no chiuso
[Musica]
Noo Bravo son una Bravo bravo
Ah sono
arrabbiatissima sono la maestra tritta
ossa e oggi verifica Chi ha studiato
vincerà il libro di Anita e chi non ha
studiato le distruggerò il
cellulare No ma io ho appena comprato il
mio nuovo iPhone 15 Pro ma tanto son
sicuro di poter copi non riuscirà a
distrugger Meno male ho studiato ma
spero di aver studiato abbastanza Spero
che non distrugga il mio di cellulare Il
mio ha già lo schermo rotto però ho
paura che me lo distrugga meglio
metterlo via io col mio telefono vecchio
altro che questi nuovi cellulari eh Il
mio telefono è proprio migliore
indistruttibile e non si scarica la
batteria Ora faremo azione di geografia
Ditemi subito Qual è la capitale
d'Italia Roma Sì sì Roma bravi ma questa
qua era troppo facile V qual è la
capitale della Francia Vediamo se lo sai
la capitale della
Francia
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grossa no è
Parigi è quella della
Germania al
100%
[Musica]
wuster non èer
stupido fatto malissimo così fa ero
sicuro che fosse mio ma cosa fusa la
capitale di dove io sono nato è Berlino
perché il mio i son tedesco ia ia è
quella della Spagna qual è È quella
della Spagna
[Musica]
St Non lo
so Ma cosa stai dicendo e
[Musica]
Madrid che cappello ah Uffa sono stanca
eh di te Billy Anita Dimmi qual è la
capitale dell'Ungheria Sì lo so la so è
Budapest Brava Anita Almeno tu studi
sempre cellulare Salvo per ora Ora tocca
a Vitale Vitale Qual è la capitale della
Grecia Io lo so io lo so e se non lo sai
ti spezzò le
ossa e poi con questa gomma ti
cancellerò la faccia mi V spezza le ossa
mi cancella la
faccia capitale della
Grecia adene adene E
adene bravo Vitale te la sei
scampata schiappe Dimmi qual è la
capitale della
Svizzera Questa è difficilissima eh Tu
pensi che io dica Zurigo perché tutti
credono che sia Zurigo la capitale della
Svizzera è Berna Berna bellissima città
Io sono andato molte volte a Berna ho
fatto di corsi meravigliosi ho scoperto
il non mi ricordo bene neanche il nome
però era la cellula fotochimica la
cellula fotochimica è andata oltre il
tubo di
trull
car Sì però basta schiappe è giusto però
basta raccontarci la storia della tua
vita Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita A
proposito di lupi mannari e vampiri nel
mio nuovo libro La città stregata c'è
una
trasformazione in lupo mannaro è un
mistero da risolvere se non ce l'hai
ancora Prendilo subito perché per i
primi a prenderlo ci sarà in regalo un
poster autografato e ricordati di
cliccare mi piace sotto a questo video
Prova a cliccare mi piace entro 3
secondi 3 2 1 tempo scaduto Oh basta Ma
perché sempre io devo subire la Furia
della maestra Ho un'idea questa volta
userò il cellulare così potrò trovare
tutte le risposte su internet e Adesso
torniamo alla mia vittima
preferita Billy Dimmi qual è la capitale
del Regno Unito la capitale del Regno
Unito
[Musica]
Londra giusto Billy mi ha sorpreso e
adesso Digi Qual è la capitale
dell'Irlanda la capitale dell'Irlanda
Dublino Ehi ma non è giusto S
barande fatti fatti tui il secch o no
Bravo Billy maestro
abarat Billy l'ho visto io S Sì
l'abbiamo visto anche noi sta guardando
il cellulare di nascosto
cosa no no maest no no no
no mio iPhone no il mio ione maestra No
non gli faccio così impari Questo è il
primo avvertimento Se ti comporti di
nuovo male te lo spaccherò questo
cellulare e soprattutto non vincerai il
libro di Anita Ah no Il mio telefono
devo trovare un modo per riprendermelo e
adesso verifica di matematica copiate
quello che scrivo la
lavagna adesso che la maestra È
distratta Ho un'idea per riprendermi il
cellulare gli farò un bello
[Musica]
scherzetto La maestra è tonta che
cos'era questo rumore La maestra è tonta
Chi è che usa dire che io sono tonta
provieni da lì vado a vedere adesso che
è uscito dalla classe posso andare a
riprendermi C
[Musica]
dulore La maestra è tonta ah Che cos'è
quello la maestra Sosa è
tonta Che cos'è questo che cos'è ma
questo qui sembra Billy Infatti si
assomiglia anche con gli occhii
capelli Infatti si assomiglia anche con
gli occhii capelli
basta
basta me la puoi smettere di ricopiarmi
smettere di ricopiarmi
Billy questo l'hai messo tu lì e ora
questa qui è la tua
punizione maestra fatto
malire
Scusa che cos'è quello è il cellulare
che ti avevo sequestrato no no no no no
non non è come sembra No Entra No io ti
avevo avvisato e adesso questo
cellulare lo
[Musica]
distruggo
ha rotto il telefono il telefono
rotto il mio telefono
No il mio telefono No che brutta fine
che hai fatto No avevo solo un giorno di
vita Billy ti sta così
impari non avevo mai visto un telefono
esplodere in questo modo è stato un po'
divertente devo dire Billy se l'è un po'
cercata l'aveva anche detto la maestra
di non usare i cellulari Altrimenti li
avrebbe distrutti Ed ora è il momento
del
premio
[Applauso]
Sì ce l'abbiamo tutti e tre
te lo posso leggere nella lezione di
oggi ci saranno due tipi di Challenge e
se vi
comporter male le vostre
ossa che la prima Challenge abbia
inizio
Eccomi
maestra Billy Scrivi la parola che ho
disegnato in inglese e se sbagli avrai
la penitenza più grossa degli alunni
Anche se io Bil il bullo sono bravissimo
Questo disegno è fatto proprio male Come
osi di dire al mio disegno che è fatto
male tu sei sicuro di quello che dici no
adesso che lo vedo bene È proprio una
bella banana quell eh
Ah ma sempre meno sempre piccare Aspetta
aspetta ASA Come si scrive banana in
inglese
benino
Beh ninu si scrive così ma non è una
banana è una pistola come una pistola
non ha neanche il grilletto Come fa a
essere una pistola Ora basta mi sono
[Musica]
stancata Ma quella
[Applauso]
è passa
passaa devo schivare devo
[Applauso]
schivare Ah Anita vieni alla lavagna
tocca a me tocca a me allora devo
disegnare no no no ho sbagliato devo
scrivere la parola in inglese di questo
disegno credo che siano delle labbra Ok
ce
l'ho Rita non sono delle labbra sono
delle onde guardale sono delle
onde la parola è lips labbra Giusto No
sono dei
baffi dei baffi ma sembravano D Ma
quindi Ma quindi Qual è la mia penitenza
adesso Questa è la tua
penitenza Ma come Ma quindi vuol dire
che mi devo tenere i baffi per il resto
della lezione Sì Anita Vai a posto
Ora era troppo difficile questo
turno itale Vieni alla bagna devo
scrivere la parola in inglese di questo
disegno
Sì ma non si capisce niente Che cos'è
questo Scusa quindi vuol dire che tu
stai prendendo in giro il mio disegno No
no no io non sto prendendo in giro il
disegno però davvero non capisco niente
Che cos'è sembra tipo una m con con con
dei con dei ricci all'interno ah ah no
no no no adesso adesso ho capito adesso
che cos'è si capisce benissimo È un
gabbiano si vede da lontano sei tu un
gabbiano Ahia ahia ahia ahia ahia
Gabbiano Come si scrive Gabbiano in
inglese sgab
Biano è un gabbiano quindi è uno sgab
bian in inglese Anzi no no ho sbagliato
la pronuncia è
sbian Hai indovinato No come no era una
parrucca una parrucca ora la tua
penitenza sarà metterti la parrucca devo
mettere questa Sì
Mettila come sto m fai proprio schifo E
adesso rimane così e Fat Appo
grazie grazie molto
incoraggiante Come si dice parrucca
di ok dai siti per favore che già hai
sbagliato
[Musica]
tutto fatto il disegno
stagna Scrivi in
inglese in inglese bellissimo e magari
per farmi una cortesia non in
tedesco Io capisco quello che ci qua
adesso lo
scrivo candela eh Innanzitutto candela
non si scrive neanche con la k ma si
scrive con la c di
cane non di coara io scrivo come quello
che CAP
candela non è una candela è un rossetto
adesso la tua punizione sarà mettere il
rossetto vieni
qua
Ok vai a posto Non hai stato neanche
tu mia VTO è
stancato nessuno dei quattro ha studiato
anche quelli che studiavano e adesso
passiamo alla seconda
Challenge
in questa Challenge dovrete prendere gli
ingredienti per lo Slime più bello ma Lo
dovrete fare da bendati chi sbaglia avrà
una penitenza aà Sì sono qua eh
colorante dovè Ok ok speriamo che mi
capiti un colore
[Musica]
bello Vediamo che colore
è verde Oh Uffa Ma io non voglio fare lo
Slime verde
Uffa vai vai schiapp Prendi vediamo
quale colorante riuscirò a prendere
Voglio vedere se il colore che a me
piace proviamo Proviamo Eccolo qua lo
sento è proprio questo son sicuro è
questo qui
Wow bellissimo il rosso il rosso è un
colore fortissimo è il colore che
preferisco insieme al verde chiaramente
Chi è appena stato fortunato con il
rosso Meglio del verde vediamo a Vitale
Cosa capita adesso
Vitale prendi un colore Sì sì mi prendo
subito come sto
malissimo Ok Allora io vorrei vorrei
prendere il il colore senape come la mia
maglietta Chissà se ho preso il colore
giusto com'è È bello grazie Oh Wow mi è
uscito arancio Sì forse posso fare
senape Billy prendi Sì maestra dove è
qua Ok Allora vediamo ne prendo un po'
faccio così e quello che cade è quello
giusto questo
Wow Che schifo
Oh
bellissimo
mirtillo Anita Prendi i glitter corri Ok
dove sono qua qua
dove Dai questa volta Spero che mi
capiti un bel
colore Vediamo che colore è bellissimo
viola viola e verde come uscirà Spero
comunque di vincere la Challenge
Jaen prendi un colore questa volta
prenderò un colore ancora più bello
cerco cerco cerco Ed eccolo
qua Che meraviglia È un Verde Oro un
Verde Oro Che
meraviglia Che colore ha preso ho preso
un bel colore
Beh verde ma verde col giallo ci sta
così e così posso cambiare da Vabbè
magari lo scambio con Billy
prendi un colore Sì
maestra Dov'è qui la
scatola Non lo so io lo vorrei
giallo
questo no Lo volevo giallo Cosè Allora
Celeste puoi cambiarlo con me lo
scambiamo verde per il celeste eh Che ne
pensi Fammi pensare
No certo che tu sei proprio antipatico
Billy Eh io Volevo
aiutarti Silenzio state facendo troppo
[Applauso]
casino no no no no no
no Sì è stato lui visto No no no i nonto
niente ma io volevo solo aiutarti Bell
amico e adesso la seconda Challenge
abbia inizio via Anita
inizia sriti Spero di riuscire a mettere
il colorante n la ciotola bene allora la
ciotola è
qua basta basta l'avrò messo Boh provo a
chiuderlo ok Sono riuscita a chiuderlo
ora devo prendere i glitter Eccoli
qua spero di averli messi nella ciotola
ora il
cucchiao qua qua ce l'ho io grazie Ok
Ora inizio a mischiare
no Ah ok Chissà come sta uscendo Spero
chea bellissimo Davvero è
bellissimo Sì è bellissimo Uh non vedo
l'ora di vederlo poi Ecco metto un po'
di
colorante un po' di colorante Speriamo
che vada bene chiappe ne è sporcato
tutto m io non vedo bene quindi posso
sporcare un po' di
glitter Ecco qua colore verde oro sa
cosa viene senza vedere come
girare tiro giro giro tio Ecco glitter e
poi dall'altra parte poi da questa parte
poi da questa parte poi da questa parte
Giro Giro giro giro cominci Ok
allora ok mettiamo un po' di
colorante Credo che possa battare così
[Musica]
Sì E qui il tappo Ok sì ok Ho messo il
tappo glitter ci sono già Beno Ah grazie
Allora mettiamo un po' di glitter Sì
basta basta basta Ok perfetto e adesso
mi ricordo che c'era la spatola qua la
ciotola Ah nella ciotola Ah ok allora
Giro Giro Giro giro giro vi sto mettendo
il colluttorio fermo colluttorio sì Ma
mica devo sciacquare i denti allo Slime
fermo Ok vai va bene Continua allora sì
e sta venendo bello il mio Slime Sì eh
io voglio vincere maestra Eh non sei tu
quello che dice che vinci sono io Oh ok
va bene Non volevo mica offendere Volevo
solo essere sicuro di fare un bello
Slime tutto
qua
belli Sì leva
oho l'orecchio eh eh senza benda Ora ti
han su queste calze
puzzol che
SCH così fa ora Mettila bella e va bene
va bene però più calmo mest eh fermo il
colorante Ecco metti vado
Sì è sceso Sì è sceso
sì
Boh va bene così sì che brutto ma come
brutto è bruttissimo ma avevo i colori
bellissimi ora adate i vostri
[Musica]
Slime la maestra È distratta
Questo è il momento dello scherzetto di
Bil il bullo i due colori più brutti
verde vomito
marron È arrivata l'ora di distruggere
gli Slime dei miei
compagni chissà come starò uscendo il
mio Slime Non vedo l'ora di vederlo sono
sicuro che sarà molto bello Poi mi è
capitato un colore dei glitter molto
particolari Ehi ma si sta dando Che
cos'è questo
rumore
Billy Billy dove sei Sono qui Dimmi che
cosa succede Ah no niente c'avevo un
strano
presentimento Sì qualcosa che non va Non
riesco a
capire se sento come m Mi sento
osservato m non è che c'è
qualcosa non
capisco chi c'è Chi c'è Eh schiapp ma
che cosa stai dicendo Stai parlando da
solo Sì perché ho sentito qualcosa
vicino Speriamo che stia uscendo bene il
mio
Slime i glitter erano bellissimi quelli
Viola Quindi secondo te sta uscendo
Benissimo speriamo di vincere anche
questa
Challenge Così sarò
promossa Uffa ma non si addensa mai
questo
Slime Come sta andando ragazzi eh credo
bene bene bene sento proprio che una
cosa molto bella silenzio C'è troppo
rumore tra poco scadrà il tempo avete
finito Sì sì ma abbiamo quasi finito
quasi fatto pronto pronto quasi pronto
finito proprio belli questi slan mio
sicuramente vincerà il primo bello
secondo me il mio Sarà bellissimo è il
mio è più bello di tutti qua Vedremo
vedremo pronto io non posso competere
con voi ragazzi voi siete troppo bravi
facendo gli Slime Bravo Billy Finalmente
una cosa
sensata Che strano Billy che dice queste
cose Sì infatti è un po' strano però il
mio sarà il primo premio Ehi kly ti pui
la benda sì Vediamo il
risultato è bellissimo
Oh bene le piace maestra Sì sì
finalmente forse vinco io Guardi Guardi
che sfumature belle celesti pui profumo
un sacco Eh certo L'ho fatto io vedrai
maestra che gli altri saranno molto
schifosi rispetto al mio come fai a
sapere No no è un presentimento credo di
essere più
bravo
schippen
Levati la
benda
[Musica]
Guarda non è possibile che schifo sembra
un cervello ma è brutto È brutto il mio
Slime non me l'aspettavo così il mio
Slime io volevo vincere il primo premio
il tuo Slime io lo chiamerò cervello
disgustoso perché questa cosa non si può
neanche vedere io gli do un zero
spaccato zea ho spaccato il mio Slime no
allora Vitale Sì sì sono pronto ho lo
Slime pronto ala la benda
sì oh no cosa è successo al mio Slime fa
proprio schifo ma questo non è il mio
giallo senape il colore che avevo
scelto Ma cosa sarà successo Non si è
nemmeno addato Ma io non l'avevo fatto
così lo Slime Non so che dire davvero
orribile Comunque ti do due perché è
bruttissimo ma mi dispiace io li sapevo
fare gli Slime non so che cosa sia
successo io lo chiamerò VTO di rana
maestra credo che il mio sia il più
bello perché avevo dei bellissimi
glitter posso togliere la benda
[Musica]
sì che schifo Ma che cos'è
questo ma non è possibile che io ho
fatto uno Slime così
schifoso sembra l'intestino di di un
mostro che schifo
Comunque il voto
è
tre Ma come tre ma io ero bravissima a
fare gli Slime Ehi aspetta un momento
Vitale ma anche a te è uscito così
schifoso lo Slime Ecco sì effettivamente
è schifoso anche il mio Sì anche il mio
è schifoso ma non è
che Ma scusa e lo Slime di Billy come
fai essere così bello se il nostro è
così schifoso
Billy
Billy sei
qualcosa de che che a me mi è uscito
bene lo Slime e a me avete fatto male
perché non lo sapete fare e quindi vinco
io Va bene Eh aspetta un momento ragazzi
Ho un'idea controlliamo le tasche di
Billy svuota le tasche subito dai
ragazzi cosa hai combinato Billi
P E va
bene T non c'è niente Ehi aspetta un
attimo che cosa sta succedendo qui Ehi
schiappe chiappe non toccarmi le chiappe
schiappe e
questo
Oh nella tasca di dietro maestra Billy
aveva questo colorante nella tasca di
dietro e credo che lui abbia sabotato
tutti i nostri Slime Sei stato tu a
colorare i nostri Slime è lui il
colpevole Perché i nostri slim non hanno
funzionato Esatto Che cosa hai fatto no
maestra Non l'ho fatto e non mi avete
visto nessuno ha visto niente perché
dite che sono stato io Siediti
subito come ti sei permesso a rovinare
tutti gli Slime S tu colpevole col te lo
faccio vedere io adesso maestra Ma io
non ho fatto
niente oh ah oh oh AH AH AH AH AH AH AH
AH AH AH
maestra non ho fatto niente
Ah
[Musica]
maestra